cadillacs come up with an interesting  strategy here at the detroit auto show  they roll down a new car designed  specifically to scare people in  particular BMW executives this is the  all new cadillac cts-v it looks pretty  much like a regular CTS but then there's  the V part which stands for a massive  v-shaped engine it'll make 640  horsepower that's more than a Ferrari  458 the car goes from zero to 60 in 3.7  seconds that's the stuff of Lamborghini  and Lotus as a carbon fiber hood and  spoiler recaro racing seats there's even  a feature that allows a driver to record  high-definition video on a track and  then share it on social networks oh yeah  the car goes 200 miles an hour for about  a decade Cadillacs tried to convince  buyers that it's not just for the  country-club set and then it's just as  sexy as anything coming out of Germany  this is the machine that may finally get  that message across